guys before the video starts i'm doing a
winter appeal for syria afghanistan and
ethiopia province sisters inshallah
people are literally freezing we will
never live in those conditions help me
reach my target to give them some walk
i've done the seven-day free trial of
the korani app and it exceeded all my
expectations what was the system you can
build a habit with the quran by seven
day free trial bonuses not credit card
details required at all and you decide
for yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated
the angel's cursor yeah so now they say
oh this is uh manipulate manipulating uh
your wife or you know she's telling her
that she's gonna get some kind of um a
curse or whatever maybe get sick for not
having intimacy but the issue here is
i'm the one that's being abused because
if i'm married no i am yes
sister i'm married if you're married
your partner expresses
no no
what do you mean by entitled is my wife
okay look at my wife an individual
married
is there is their wife entitled to
intimacy
no she's not
okay are they entitled to love affection
i mean
within the concerns of a marriage you
decide what's all right for you in that
marriage and you say hey my wife
never wants to have sex with me and i
don't appreciate that in a marriage you
can go no no
if you're unhappy with something in your
marriage it's within your rights to end
that marriage to seek out a new one but
we're not talking about that we're not
talking about we're talking about an
instant moment of one saying no sense to
you today
i'm talking about that so when you talk
about entitlement
what are part two parties entitled to so
for example when it comes to sex nothing
okay okay okay no no who makes this
condition by the way and secondly am i
entitled to is a man entitled to say
that when a robber goes in the house he
says to his wife go i'm locking the door
deal with the situation let me know when
it's done it has nothing to do with the
conversation it does just start is the
woman entitled to protection
no she's not okay no problem if you go
with that um angle then that means she's
not entitled to protection she's not
entitled no one's entitled to nothing
yeah
no no no
i mean when you enter into a
relationship it's up to you and the
other person in their relationships
decide what you want in that
relationship in terms of love in terms
of perfection in terms of okay yeah
that's correct
okay you mean you mean
you mean person eight person they said
you're not entitled to nothing from me
then i would say all right that's fair
but i don't want to be married to
somebody there's no problem then you
meet another guy and he said you're not
inside nothing from me then i wouldn't
be married to any man who said something
like that do you see the problem here
now what we've done is we've got a false
reality and in it and we apply it if
every man said i think if women don't
want to have sex with you that's a
problem
i'm not even talking about i'm talking
about a bigger problem here what i'm
trying to say is when you use the term
and no one is entitled to anything then
you have a society a malfunctioning
malfunctioning society because you're
saying you're not entitled to this well
if that's the case any man walking down
the road should not in any way shape
feel entitled to protect the woman
but there's a problem because now you're
gonna have woman for example imagine
sarah ever everyone what was the name
yeah the one who got killed by a police
officer
yeah okay
it was it was tragic so imagine me
walking down the road and i hear imagine
i hear her screaming
and i say and i say
i don't care
to protect me down the street because at
the end of the day well you have no
choice but to rely on him no
i don't know maybe i'm carrying right
now carrying what you're not you know
you're in the uk
[Laughter]
there are women out there that can knock
me out yeah i have nothing about that
yeah the point is this this stuff
every every person is somehow
in one way entitled not that you ask for
that for example we live in this like
forever thomas hobbs talks about
contract terrorism yeah we live in this
we live in no i know but we live in this
land if i cross the red line i'm not
going to say i never greeted these laws
you can't give me three points
you are not entitled to give me a free
point i live in this land i enjoy the a
lot of things in these lands so i have
to abide by the lord what i'm trying to
say in a nutshell sister is that the the
reality you're giving us doesn't fit in
it doesn't work
it doesn't work and if you're walking
down the road and you have been attacked
you would feel
you would want someone
thank you so what do you say the word
hope yeah and any husband would hope
that if he wants to have intimacy if he
wants to have intimacy his wife and
again the hadith actually doesn't tell
the hadith doesn't actually say that you
have to force her he just says she'll be
cursed by the
into it is helpful injury everyone here
obviously has separate beliefs no of
course that's what we're discussing but
why don't you say in a nutshell it
doesn't work in we all feel entitled
somehow i'm trying to say and there's
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with that
okay well you can feel entitled you can
feel how you do like you said you would
hope that i would hope that's good but
you know why do you feel that hope
why why don't you say you know what i i
hope that regardless if it's a man a
woman anything anybody of course of
course i would hope that if i was
getting attacked by someone with a knife
that somebody walking along would help
me
i also recognize that by doing that
whoever's helping me maybe putting
themselves in danger
there's other factors to consider in
situations like this and i would venture
to believe that i think there's things
that people should be entitled to that
you think people should not be entitled
to say that by the way
there's multiple people sleeping on the
ground i think those people deserve a
home to live in yeah
a lot of people in this country would
say oh well they're not
then why can't a woman have compassion
on her husband
but i never even said that i never even
said if a woman says stop and then i
said no you shut up if she says she
stopped and she's abusing her no no no
no what i'm saying is if we look at for
example the studies that i quoted which
i'll read for the camera again here
that's what i understand as well no no
sister no no when i'm saying the sister
when there was a study done on a woman's
sex drive in a man's sex drive yeah and
the studies
no it's not generally it's a study that
was done the study shows very clearly
that a man's sexual drive is nowhere
compared to a woman's meaning that how
always
this is this is this is yes look i'll
read it for you
there's exclusive there's i mean there's
certain situations we're talking
generally it does look let me let me
really study that
okay let me read it from the system yeah
i heard you uh
okay okay let me just read it just about
context because before people come and
start saying that i'm condoning uh
husband rape and wife yeah the sex drive
refers to the strength of sexual
motivation across many different studies
and measures men have shown to have more
frequent and more intense intense sexual
desires than women as reflective and
spontaneous thoughts about sex frequency
and variety of sexual fantasies desired
frequency of intercourse desired number
of partners masturbation liking for
various sexual practices willingness
willingness to forgo sex initiating
versus refusing sex making sacrifices
for sick and other measures listen
carefully sister no contrary findings
indicating stronger sexual motivation
among women were found what that means
is the following sister you are created
in a certain way i am creating a certain
way a man
i i know i know but what i'm saying is
biological difference is this a man is
stronger than a woman but i believe a
woman is mentally more stronger than a
man the studies are shown as well i
believe men are women and that's the
reason why men tend to commit suicide
more yeah
this is a fact so therefore what we're
seeing is biologically that a man's
desire for the opposite gender is more
frequent and more stronger therefore if
a man comes to his wife he has married
and he loves and they love each other
and says i want to have intimacy and she
says
no and when i mean no it's not i'm not
feeling well i'm tired i'm on my menses
i'm not talking about that he's not the
mistake no no no no no no no no no but
this one trying to sister if this woman
says no
says i don't care that means she doesn't
want to be with me okay okay no okay
what i'm saying is is she abusing him
yes or no
yes he is
okay okay okay okay
okay all right okay if that's the case
no problem no no no no no no you can't
take our biology
why not when it comes to strength we do
okay because i agree there's violence
yes and the reason i don't i mean i
don't know i'm not a biologist like i'm
not a scientist i don't know i can't
tell you
but
biologically let's say when humans were
first
like devolving
the aim
you know survival of the fittest the aim
yeah is to spread your seed as much as
you can populate the earth as much as
you can but we don't live in the dark
ages we live in an age where women have
and we don't live in an age where we
have to succumb to every biological no
that's fine it's about how is it i'm not
talking about the dark ages or the cave
agents so what i'm trying to say in a
nutshell is this
and man what's in is this studies that
show a man's sex drive is higher than a
woman
but when it starts excuse me if you have
a specific need in a specific area
you're not gonna die okay okay okay okay
one second after one second let's
reverse it
the studies show a woman's sex drive is
500 times higher than a man ali this
child friendly conversation no no it's
not i'm so sorry i'm saying guys i'm so
sorry yeah sorry sorry sorry sorry
kids please leave the area um
so if if if the baby she won't
remember anything uh so the thing is if
that's the case and if a man if a man a
wife says you know i won't have intimacy
and he says no you're not getting
nothing
i swear to god feminists will lose
they'll rip their hair out they would
rip their hair out in high pot he's
sexually abusing her oh she wants his
intimacy some love and affection oh it's
okay when it's a woman poor woman but
when is a man be a man
this is this is double standards
because if i'm if i'm in a relationship
with someone and i say
either
either something changes or i leave or
he leaves yeah that's simple
that's not good i'm not
talking about a sister of course if i
was that man i'll tell him to go and get
married again right no long-term i'll
tell him straight away
go and get married again because because
because if it's not working out of
course looking this time we have divorce
like jewish in the jewish
uh religion a woman is not allowed to
get divorced until the husband initiates
islam we don't have a wonderful divorce
a man can get a divorce my issue is not
that there is abuse happening towards
the man
and i'm not saying the man has to force
himself i'm not saying that what i'm
saying is
if she says no yeah she is abusing him
and for you yes tell me why not please
can someone tell me and with evidence
why not
see what you're doing now you see what i
mean there's a
reason why
good assumptions for your sister that's
good maybe it's this i understand but
what i'm saying is the following yeah if
the situation is that he's a good guy he
doesn't cheat on him he provides for her
he loves her okay came home one day yeah
she won't do that
i know i know
okay i'm saying if she did okay i'm not
talking about it though she's not well
and it's always she's not always always
no way not yeah let's say she's doing it
she's doing it
of course that's not right okay is that
abused
at the end of the day a woman has agency
over herself as much as you have agency
over us yeah i know i know since she
doesn't what i'm saying is is it abusive
agency horse is not abuse there is
nothing abusive about that okay no
problem okay if that's the case you work
you walk down the road sister you walk
down the road a man with a man with a
gun and i just watch you get killed and
that's not i believe that's a form of
abuse no you know why no one said excuse
me if a woman who's vulnerable being
attacked by a group of men and i am
there getting popcorn wow look at that
one second
another one i know what i'm trying to
say is this is what i'm doing a part of
that give me the tap i have full
capabilities to stop it or help her if i
choose to step back like they say the
person that is silent is this is the
silent devil or something along those
lines yeah the point i'm trying to say
is this it's a lack of compassion
okay call it whatever you like lack of
compassion any other words
the point i'm just trying to say is that
men do get abused also women yes let's
get this right just because a woman
cries
like if he was a woman here well i swear
to god there's somebody crying and
saying my husband i told him to have
intimacy with me and he didn't i swear
to god we'll start a charity for her
we'll do a fundraising right now she
raised twenty thousand pounds it is but
when he's a man and this is why men
commit suicide because they can't
express their feelings if they cry
they're a little whimped so the point
i'm trying to make is that there are
women that abuse and when it comes to
this when we talk about biology we show
the study that shows that manchester
united is higher than women's but let's
talk about physical
what you can talk about the point i'm
trying to say is i'm more stronger than
a woman but some women are kickboxing
they're more stronger than me that can
help me out
generally so if that's the case if i'm
walking with my wife and somebody comes
and takes a knife out
in that very instance my wife is
entitled to protection from me
period i can't come and say oh darling
you know sorry
call me when you're done she will come
and say this guy you know what we call
it i'll be called the biggest names on
the stream
coward you are this you're the one the
reason she got stabbed you are but why
is it when it's biologically that i'm
stronger than her in that very instance
it's okay but when it comes to the sex
right oh no no no it's not abuse how do
you find the word entitled
i would say in a nutshell it is
something that is
maybe i might be wrong innately that we
have that for example if i say if i give
you a coffee i would expect a thank you
or i would maybe be entitled to not be
abused or insulted
it's an entitlement that you don't have
to give it's something that i expect
so you get it
yeah so i it's something that i expect
subconsciously but it's not something
that you have to do but when you don't
do it it tells me a little bit about you
so if you come and say ali hibo this is
i bought you an iphone
13 argument okay
and i say
okay
bye
now this is not about who i am now and
it tells you a lot about who you are so
international what i'm just trying to
say is that when we give these scenarios
is that when it's a woman or when a
woman cries it's it's
why man
men are more
psychologically weaker i believe yeah
and we see that yeah women tend to get
over relationships faster there's
studies that show that you know you know
you have that meme which shows you know
the first week of breakup the man is
like
and the girl is like and then three
weeks later the guy is crying and the
woman uh it's it's we see that she came
trying to say so i'm just saying let's
just be consistent and accept this fact
that if a man for example is married
loves his wife he's good to his wife and
he wants to have intimacy and he calls
her to her and she says no that is a
form of abuse
i believe that and if anyone can tell me
why i'm wrong i don't know how to
respect that it's the same way you know
i believe it's a form of abuse if she's
being attacked and i just watch it
happen
see how
is that one's gonna kill you the other
one doesn't like the refusal of intimacy
doesn't kill the man but in an instance
where a man takes a step back and lets
his wife get stabbed that's death so one
is worse off yeah but that's the two
very different scenarios well it is but
that's the boy
but why is it strong because one is one
person
exactly
but based on biology we're talking about
but we're talking about how men and
women are created that's why i'm giving
you that example because one is an
example of how we are created when it
comes to the sex drive and the other is
how we create it based on our physical
abilities so i'm giving i'm saying as a
man i have these this is my weakness for
example a man's weakness is is he has a
high sex drug you have to have intimacy
a woman's weakness is she's physically
weak so i need to cater for her there
and she would need to cater for me here
now this doesn't mean force if i say if
emma says to his wife come and have
intimacy she says no i believe that man
should say you know what i want to end
this relationship i'm not saying you
should go and
force yourself on it which man would in
the right mind do that i'm gonna say
that i'm saying what she's doing is
abuse and he has a right for divorce
don't you think that might be better for
no no this is absolutely you know what
this is bob you're kicking the guy on
the floor
yeah yeah you're kicking me that's what
you're doing and as a man how could you
say that
how could you see that as a man he is
he's been refused intimacy and on top of
that you control your sex tribes and
studies show that the way a man is
created that his sex drive is nowhere
compared to a woman and i'll talk about
what else can you imagine if you say
this to a woman imagine studies show a
woman's sex drive is higher than a man
and then she's like well i want intimacy
he's not giving it to me sister control
your sex drive what's wrong with you you
know what grab you know what does this
this guy say this guy's a violin he's
oppressor he's an oppressor
this is what i'm saying i don't think
it's right i think we need to really you
know and and like i said before
in in islam we have hadith of the
prophet peace be upon him where a woman
came and complained that her husband
doesn't sexually satisfy her
and the prophecy would have allowed the
divorce to happen so in islam it's not
like oh you know if a woman is not
sexually satisfied she has a valid
reason for the boost
exactly for the woman
okay
what happened to the man